[Musique]
athènes mai 2014 la campagne électorale
bat son plein dans les rues les
militants dogdoré sont plus que jamais
mobilisés
tous les tracts doivent être distribués
tous les tracts doivent partir mais
personne ne doit s'éloigner aux
élections européennes régionales et
municipales le parti néo nazi grec
présente un peu partout des candidats
je suis candidate au conseil régional
vous pouvez voter pour moi si vous
voulez merci et bonne journée
malgré l'évidence des symboles aube
dorée refuse l'étiquette néonazis et se
disent simplement nationaliste
une chose est sûre avec ses bureaux
flambant neuf au coeur d'athènes aube
dorée désormais durablement installé
dans le paysage politique du pays
[Musique]
le phénomène doré c'est le produit d'un
dysfonctionnement majeur de l'état grec
depuis 2010 doublée d'une crise
économique sans précédent
[Musique]
aujourd'hui après sept ans de récession
les grecs sont à genoux le taux de
chômage dépasse les 26 % ils ont le
sentiment d'être abandonnés à eux mêmes
face à eux un état en faillite et sans
réponses concrètes
[Applaudissements]
depuis 2008 vingt mille manifestations
souvent violentes ont été recensés dans
tout le pays de nombreuses banques et
bâtiments officiels incendiés et des
victimes cinq morts parmi les
manifestants et des dizaines de blessés
du pain béni pour home doré dans ce
contexte chaotique le parti néo-nazi a
multiplié l'ouverture de bureaux dans
tout le pays
depuis son entrée au parlement en juin
2012 rien ni personne ne semble pouvoir
arrêter l'ascension du parti néo nazi
qui a fait de la violence une arme
politique
ça suffit maintenant tu ne parle plus il
ne part plus
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
casse toi sale ordures je suis
nationaliste mais aussi un art trois
nationalistes les casse toi sale [__]
ordures mais pourquoi tu m'as sur
aube dorée profite alors de la
complaisance du gouvernement et de la
police pour multiplier les attaques
envers les syndicalistes et les immigrés
[Musique]
allez
hélas
là
et
le 17 janvier 2013 un jeune pakistanais
de 27 ans 16 athlètes man et poignardé
par deux hommes en noir la police
retrouvera chez eux des tracts dogdoré
la résistance pendant pleurs
[Musique]
mais huit mois plus tard pavlos fils à
ce rappeur anti fasciste est lui aussi
tué en pleine rue par un cadre dogdoré
georges groupe à kas c'est le meurtre de
trop
d'un seul coup les grecs et les pouvoirs
publics semblent découvrir l' en asie
il doit les jugements
dix jours après la mort du rappeur par
l'hospice as le fondateur dogdoré et six
députés sont inculpés pour appartenance
à une organisation criminelle
merde de démocratie d'autres
arrestations suivront contre toute
attente trois députés sont relâchées
dont les plus virulents il est à ce
panel iota ross et il y as cassidy aris
33 ans agronome de formation
étoile montante du parti
officiellement aube dorée condamne le
meurtre de byblos fils as ces députés ni
même connaître son assassin
on a appris qu'ils étaient ceux sur ou
pas qui a c'est ce qu'il a fait mais
après l'assassinât je ne connaissais pas
aucun de nous ne le connaissais c'était
juste un sympathisant parmi tant
d'autres et rien de plus nadal
pourtant lors de nos deux années de
tournage auprès d'ohb doré nous l'avons
souvent croisés
ici aux côtés du député pagnotta hausse
lors d'une distribution de nourriture en
juillet 2013
la trois mois plus tard toujours en
uniforme à une manifestation du parti
d'épreuves inédites à ce jour que ropac
et à c'était bien un membre actif
dogdoré et non un simple sympathisant
[Musique]
c'est alors qu'un groupe terroriste
d'extrême gauche inconnu jusque-là venge
le meurtre du rappeur pawlowski sas deux
militants de redorer sont abattus de
sang-froid au pied de leur qg
le parti tient ses martyrs
pour dorer désormais jouer aux victimes
mais continue ses démonstrations de
force comme dans cette cérémonie de
nuremberg version locale à l'automne
dernier
à la tribune il ya ce cas-ci diariste
lance sa campagne électorale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'objectif donc doré et de placer des
élus dans toutes les grandes villes du
pays pas seulement à athènes
thessalonique on nous dirait on veut
gérer le pays avec des mains propres on
écrase la corruption et qu'il y ait à
nouveau une purification politique et
que la loi règne
nos priorités seront les suivants 1 la
corruption et le gaspillage d'argent
public
la criminalité 3 le commerce illégal ce
sont là les trois grandes questions qui
préoccupent les grecs et quand je parle
de criminalité et de commerce illégal je
parle évidemment exclusivement des
étrangers ça ne concerne pas les grecs
des grecs tenté de voter hop doré le
centre d'athènes en compte beaucoup tous
ces damnés de la crise pour qui le
moindre sou est compté comme celle là
vous en voulez plus ça me suffit ça
coûte combien un euro t la veuve de 65
ans vit proche du seuil de pauvreté un
seuil qui concerne désormais un tiers
des grecs
euros
je viens ici parce que c'est moins cher
quand je peux m'en sortir ailleurs je
n'y arrive pas
au marché notre présence déclenche très
vite des commentaires
vous le dis que sur vos chaînes que les
gens ont faim les gens fin et le
gouvernement ne sont mêmes pas encore
rendu compte qu'ils aillent tous se
faire [__]
non non ne dites pas ça ces mots sont
interdits pourquoi ne pas le dire
pourquoi regardez comment ils ont laissé
les gens non non tout va bien tout le
monde venait me demander à moi aussi ce
que je vais voter
je vais vous dire la vérité
moi je vais voter pour la gauche
radicale pour changer les données de
madame merkel
c'est ça que je vais voter on doit
réagir
gauche radicale ou aube dorée dans le
marché aux poissons le choix est clair
ici lé drapeau grec flotte en nombre un
symbole depuis quelques années confisqué
par le parti néo-nazi
au doré de plus en plus puissantes elle
a tout ce qu'il lui faut pour prospérer
la misère la faim le malheur le chômage
tout y
[Musique]
est fait avec ce morceau de fromage on
va pouvoir tenir un bon moment
une fois les cours se ranger s'est elle
a fait ses comptes elle touche une
retraite de 655 euros
avec cette somme elle doit vivre et
faire vivre aussi son fils et son neveu
et sa petite fille
dans une telle situation aller chercher
de l'aide auprès d'ohb doré est la
solution la plus simple que les trouver
j'ai été deux fois leurs distributions
de nourriture ils m'ont donné des pommes
de terre des tomates
raisins des poissons
d'eau réorganise encore une distribution
de nourriture j'irai c'est sûr
j'ai été demandé de l'aide à la mairie
mais il demande un tas de justificatifs
pas chez aube dorée
ils sont des milliers comme celle là à
faire la queue partout au bord et
organisent des distributions de
nourriture
exclusivement réservé aux grecs
chrétiens et blanc les bénéficiaires
doivent impérativement montrer leur
carte d'identité
des heures d'attentes pour ramener chez
soi de quoi tenir ne serait ce que
quelques jours
je suis venu car j'ai de gros problèmes
financiers je dois manger quand même mes
enfants sont au chômage mon mari est
malade et je veux que justice soit
rendue contre ces voleurs de
gouvernement
vous pensez comme doré peut le faire
oui même si je suis en désaccord avec
leur procès les ils le peuvent et je
veux vraiment que ceux qui ont vidé les
caisses de l'état soit jugé pour honorer
ses distributions très fréquentes font
partie intégrante de sa stratégie de
campagne
voilà
on va t'en s'il te plaît bien ici un
instant
lors de ces dons de nourriture les
députés dr et comme il ya ce cas-ci
diaries sont toujours présents et bien
visible ça va suffire ça va être juste
on a amené cinq camions mais on ne
pensait pas qu'il y aurait autant de
monde
de nombreux bénéficiaires et autant
d'électeurs potentiels
[Musique]
cet hiver devant le parlement plus de
dix mille militants se sont réunis à
l'appel du parti à l'ordre du jour la
libération immédiate du fondateur d'ovh
doré ainsi que de deux de ses députés
doré n'est pas entrée au parlement avec
les chars comme leurs médias corrompus
le raconte mais avec votre vote est un
slogan les voleurs en prison ces salles
exigences du moment
comme d'habitude cassis diaries
galvanise ses troupes sans aucune note
nous nous sommes l'avenir est aux le
passé de quoi convaincre les derniers
indécis
paris ce n'est pas de cela militant
dogdoré de longue date cet ancien pilote
d'hélicoptère de l'armée s'est investit
de plus en plus dans le mouvement au fil
des années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faire de deux enfants ravis ce procès
d'aujourd'hui un petit restaurant
devenue le point de ralliement de ses
amis militants
et balle allait sous la quille
et tout ce qu'on dit sur vous les sexion
d'assaut les agressions racistes c'est
vrai
non ça n'existe pas
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on est
simplement nationaliste et rien d'autre
on aime simplement notre pays
ce qui m'a fait entrer de façon active
dans aube dorée
s'étaient tous les problèmes avec cette
crise
est la solution qui doit être donnée
doit être nationaliste c'est à dire
c'est à dire c'est à dire qu'on peut y
arriver tout seul on a besoin de
personne on est un peuple
une civilisation un pays qui a tout on a
besoin de personne ni de l'allemagne ni
des américains ou des juifs
[Musique]
ce qu'a réussi au doré personne d'autre
ne l'a réussi ni les socialistes ni les
communistes celle entraîne des uns
envers les autres
on vient de toutes les couches de la
société nous sommes des forces
hétéroclites
du plus bas au plus haut niveau de la
société
mais on est regroupé solidaire et on
s'entraide de façon désintéressée
parce que le danger en ce moment est à
nos portes
le lendemain rallys nous accueille chez
lui ici tout le monde soutient son
engagement dans l'aube dorée surtout sa
femme ioulia
est connue nous avions les mêmes
convictions cela continuer ce que nous
décidons nous décidons toujours en
commun est pas belle maman
dans cette famille de militaires depuis
des générations on a commencé à voter au
bord et bien avant la faillite du pays
ce n'est pas que la crise économique
c'est également les questions nationales
mon autre fils aussi est mis à terre
comme mon mari je ne peux plus accepter
la réduction des budgets de la défense
ni les humiliations que subit
régulièrement notre patrie je n'en peux
plus
comme la plupart des cadres dogdoré
râler se dit féru d'histoire dans sa
bibliothèque de nombreux ouvrages sur la
deuxième guerre mondiale sa passion
le nationaliste grec lire nous lisons
pour apprendre c'est ce qui nous rend
super héros aux autres
et pour harris tous les auteurs se
valent
même quand je lis aussi en grec ça c'est
une copie mais je vais aussi en version
originale acheté à londres dans une
galerie
là c'est l'original regardez-la
à l'époque il ya eu 4 millions
d'exemplaires imprimés mais ça veut rien
dire que j'ai le mein kampf de hitler
je les lui c'est tout
2 exemplaire de mein kampf chez lui
malgré tout rares il refuse l'étiquette
de raciste ou de nazis
on est restés pauvres tous ceux qui
désormais quittent leur pays pour venir
en grèce pourquoi je me le coltine moi
pourquoi pas la france
pourquoi jacques huret tous ces milliers
de clandestins qui viennent du pakistan
des musulmans qui essaient de m'imposer
leur religion qui demandent des droits
et je ne sais quoi d'autre et viennent
faire leur djihad en grèce
aris assume ce discours anti-immigrés sa
caution ses actions humanitaires passé
moi quand j'étais en afrique j'ai aidé
tant que j'ai pu mais pour qu'il reste
chez lui le noir pas qu'ils viennent
chez moi altéré ma race il n'y a pas de
noirs dans la race grecque
et pour préserver la race grec hop doré
va jusqu'au bout de sa logique elle
organise des collectes de sang grec pour
les grecs
il faut prendre tous les gens qui
attendent et ceux qui sont jusque là
passent en priorité
selon la loi sauf urgence l'hôpital doit
réserver ce sens pour les patients
grecque
on essaye de faire tout ce que l'on peut
pour aider le fuse de jantes aussi
une mise en scène de plus pour aube
dorée en cette période de campagne
électorale
aujourd'hui c'est la journée de collecte
de sang nationale pour au doré c'est
encore une action sociale de notre parti
comme vous voyez il y a des centaines de
gens des concitoyens qui offre un peu de
leur sang ces actions vont continuer
malgré les réactions inadmissible que
cela suscite
les actions chocs provocatrice c'est la
tactique doré et c'est sur la toile que
le parti poursuit son travail de
propagande
depuis le quartier général du parti
qu'il y ait ce cas-ci diariste parle
t'on militants une fois par semaine via
internet avec des messages comme sur ce
tract toujours teinté de provocation
j'ai aimé cette photo dès le premier
jour à ma sortie du tribunal je me suis
alors dit que le meilleur message pour
ces élections passerait par cette image
elle est vraie ce n'est pas un montage
nous avons subi une véritable
persécution mais nous y faisons pas ça
avec le sourire on nous traite de nazis
de fascistes mais on nous a aussi traité
de terroriste être gauchiste parce que
nous on n'a jamais commis de crime on
n'a jamais volé de l'argent public comme
ils n'ont rien à dire sur nous ils ont
inventé toute cette histoire de nazisme
et même de satanisme on a entendu tout
un tas de bêtises sur nous car ils n'ont
rien à nous reprocher nous on a les
mains
[Musique]
pourtant la police a fourni récemment la
presse de nombreuses photos qui prouvent
le contraire
[Musique]
nous retrouvons radès deux fois par
semaine l'ancien pilote se rend dans les
bureaux dogdoré de son quartier pour la
première fois il autorise des
journalistes à pénétrer dans ses locaux
bonsoir tout le monde tout va bien à
l'entrée les gros bras montent la garde
bonsoir tiens ya les caméras avec toi à
laitages les sympathisants sont déjà
nombreux
travis lui est chargé de motiver les
troupes de recruter de nouveaux membres
et de collecter des fonds
voilà là c'est les coupons qui
permettent de soutenir le parti grâce
aux dons des militants
ici on entretient le culte du passé
glorieux du pays dont aube dorée se
réclame sans cesse
en novembre dernier le local a été
attaqué et saccagé par des opposants
depuis ras laisse à renforcer la
sécurité
ici nous avons des portes blindées
et à l'entrée des bureaux une grille
supplémentaires un système d'alarmé des
caméras extérieures caméra intérieure
on est en guerre une guerre permanente
et de longue durée
est-ce qu'on peut organiser la salle on
peut
ce soir les sympathisants sont réunis
pour une lecture commentée du journal du
parti
au programme un fait divers sordide une
jeune fille agressée et violée par un
migrant
si on réagit on est des racistes
le sommes nous
et moi sommes nous je ne sais pas je
vous le demande sommes nous des racistes
nous on est nationaliste
nationaliste on n'est pas fasciste
on n'est pas nazi
que nous voulons c'est la libération de
notre patrie et qu'il nous foute la paix
la réunion se termine
alice lui a oublié qu'il portait un
micro et donne des consignes à
constantine à la militante qui de nous
parler le lendemain
le lendemain nous retrouvons constantine
est en campagne elle nous répète alors
fidèlement sa leçon
ce ne sont pas les grecs ont fait la
shoah n'a aucun rapport avec cela si
cela a eu lieu nous on n'est pas
responsable
constantine a vient d'un milieu très
aisé assistante juridique elle a perdu
son emploi l'année dernière
désormais elle est candidate aux
élections régionales pour redorer
je vous donne un tract vous voulez bien
vous savez ce que c'est pour moi oui je
sais vous êtes d'accord les chefs dr
essais des prisonniers politiques
chacun ses opinions
c'est à dire
j'y crois et j'y crois pas
c'est à dire c'est bon
les gens ont peur de fait tous les prix
le trac devant la caméra sans le refusez
ça veut dire beaucoup ça veut dire je
suis d'accord avec vous sinon ils nous
l'auraient lancé à la figure
le lendemain constantine à nous invite
chez elle
bonjour
pour nous parler de son engagement
constantine a demandé à des amis de
venir elle aussi militante convaincue
n'as tu fais du thé
mon cas ce qui m'a fait forte impression
en allant voir au mont doré c'est qu'il
parlait de la grèce la grèce de la grèce
de la grèce et des grecs et puis à la
fin ils ont dit le vais vous chanter
l'hymne national
je me suis dit suis-je
je vous dis moi je n'y croyais pas
j'avais la chair de poule je pleurais
vraiment je pleurais quand j'ai entendu
l'hymne national j'ai dit c'est fini je
voterai désormais pour obturer
la grèce aux grecs chrétiens et la grèce
appartient aux grecs tu n'es grecque qui
te parle de venir
mois avant je veux tu es pour le parti
socialiste
jusqu'en avril début mai 2012 quand je
suis allé m'inscrire à aube où dort et
peu avant les premières élections
avec tout ce qu'on avait entendu sur eux
les rumeurs les accusations de
terrorisme
au début je me suis dit c'est qui ces
gens
j'ai quand même demandé leur programme
et me convenait à son père simple
en fait
c'étaient des gens super sympa déjà très
bien élevé
des militants sympathique
serviable
à l'image de harris désormais candidat à
la mairie d'un quartier huppé de la
banlieue d'athènes
[Musique]
il se la met plus haut en sécurité pour
que les autres les gauchos ne lâche pas
jusqu'ici au bord et faisait le plein
des voix dans les quartiers les plus
défavorisés
aujourd'hui elle vise aussi les classes
supérieures
ici aux dernières élections au doré a
obtenu 6 9% des voix
maintenant on est à plus de 10 ce sont
des gens de toutes les classes sociales
mais essentiellement des moyens et hauts
revenus eux aussi touchés par la crise
harris a revêtu sa plus belle chemise
pour son premier meeting
désormais au bord et liste son image et
son discours il ne faut plus effrayé
mais séduire les citoyens bien sous tous
rapports
[Applaudissements]
je veux des grecs qu'ils pensent
des grains qui peuvent créer
je veux l'esprit du lys
et l'audace d'achille
les élections montreront si les grecs se
sont laissés séduire par cette stratégie
une certitude six militants et cadres
dorés se veulent plus fréquentable
aujourd'hui le rim ne lui ne laisse
guère de doute sur leurs intentions
[Musique]
qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passionné des
guides accusés
djigo
[Applaudissements]